[Music]
how can we make music that evokes
longing and desire
and mysticism music that sounds like
you're flying towards the stars
in this video we will explore the
musical style of the complex and
enigmatic russian composer
alexander skriyabin who was born on
january 6th
1872 he studied piano and composition at
the moscow conservatory where he was
classmates with sergey rahmaninov
throughout the 1890s he toured as a
pianist composer
often premiering works of his such as
his piano concerto and early piano
sonatas
from the 1900s onwards scrabbin's
musical language started to break
further away from traditional western
harmony simultaneously scrippin also
began exploring more and more ideas
related to theosophy
mysticism and his own personal theories
that clean enough yeah i think we can
handle that
we are for instance tomorrow going to do
a sequence of
spherogen failures a man who writes
basically in his mature years using one
chord his magic chord again and again
and again
until you think enough you know and yet
a man who wanted
perfume color all the the you know the
application of every every sensual
aspect applied
to the perception of the music he was
indeed an eccentric character with
desires to create utopia through his
music
such as with his mysterium a piece
involving all different forms of art
also known as akazamt kunzverk which he
intended to be performed in the
himalayas as a week-long event
that would eventually be followed by
both an apocalypse
and a reformation of the world his music
is often dismissed
in the west as something terribly
eccentric and
very strange his late music where it is
idiomatic
totally dramatic one can easily
characterize him as a megalomaniac and
self-indulgent idealist
but a deeper look into his music reveals
him as a hopeless romantic
that was enveloped by his own ideas of
universal redemption
one thing is for certain though his
music holds a significant place in music
history
in the following sections i'll first
break down elements of scriobin's
musical style while analyzing a
selection
of scrabbon's piano works then i'll
reconstruct these notes as i create an
arrangement of happy birthday in the
style of scriabin
to narrow down the focus of his
ever-changing style i've chosen to base
my studies on the earlier half of his
compositions
as a pianist playing scriabin is like
using
the entire keyboard and
almost feeling like this is not enough
because he just uses so much of these
registers
[Music]
so here we have a lot of sequences and
it's all leaping upwards we have
it being played let's say here and then
it gets repeated slightly higher
and then higher bigger and tension is
growing
all the while whilst kriyabin broke down
traditional rules
he clung to the inherited form this is
the opening of sonata number two opus
19.
we start with the short phrase
something similar
so two short phrases now along
so this our format is quite traditional
it's following the model of many of the
earlier composers short short long
[Music]
change change change the attitude
it's like a bird which is flying flying
suddenly birds decide
maybe there's a fish no
so the way he switches moods very
suddenly
also reminds me of schumann
[Music]
so you have something delicate and all
of a sudden you open up
and it becomes much more extroverted and
here odd groupings
groups of five
and it invites this very fluid type of
[Music]
phrasing
a lot of times when i'm listening to
skriyabin i think of
molasses that evaporates all of a sudden
because sometimes
the music even if it's not dense with
many notes it just feels very thick
and then all of a sudden it just
evaporates and becomes
extremely delicate really thin
[Music]
also very naive and
very attractive in its naivety of course
beautifully composed and shoppiness of
course
but not entirely
the left hand especially is very
chopin-esque
for example chopin's fourth blood
versus
belcanto singing
[Music]
romantic
so i was exaggerating here but there is
an inner line that comes in which is
very typical of screaming
it makes reading it super difficult it's
also worth noting that due to an injury
in his youth scrabbin dealt with chronic
pain in his right arm and hand this
became worse during his conservatory
years due to repetitive stress from
practicing
and prompted him to focus more on his
left hand
consequently one can find exceptionally
present and elaborate left hand parts in
his piano compositions
many people point out that four sonata
was a
step a borderline
into harmonically into unknown regions
and also spiritually again
all of these beautiful slides
and very smooth voice leading for
example here
if you start from the a b flat
b
[Music]
c
and i think that's what makes it sound
so smooth and
beautiful
the three important states in
states of mind or states of spirit
as he said in his music the one
one of them is longing the next one is
the flight of the free will free spill
spirit
and the last one is the ecstasy
so you hear all of these pairs of notes
[Music]
or even at the beginning
[Music]
these are like trophies you hear this a
lot in rap these days a trophy is a foot
that has a stressed syllable
followed by a weak syllable so for
example
teenage mutant ninja turtles
the stress syllable in this case falls
on what we might consider the musical
downbeat
so something like this this is his more
tumultuous
side
it sounds like there are multiple layers
but it's really just
it's very clever i really like that i
appreciate it
as a pianist
and it's challenging
because you just have to make it sound
like one
wave and it's like that with a lot of
scrivener's music i feel like
in order to hear what he's going for you
have to have a certain amount of
distance from it
almost like looking at a picture if
you're too close maybe you're paying
attention to the pixels it doesn't make
as much sense but you really have to
just
step back and then then you see it in a
different way
[Music]
something like this this may be a bit of
a stretch but
if i imagine a swing rhythm to be added
i feel like a lot of these chords a lot
of these lines would make
a lot of sense
i think that's why a lot of jazz
musicians love skriyabin if you
analyze a lot of his music as chord
changes with
a lot of extensions added it's
quite appropriate to be translated into
the jazz idiom
it's quite ambiguous because you don't
know where you're going
so it's kind of unsettling but at the
same time it's it puts you in this
dreamy
world
[Music]
i want to talk a bit about the mystic
horde of course
this is the famous chord
you can look at it in many different
ways it's been analyzed
to death and seriously if you go down
that
rabbit hole you can find so much
information about it for me personally
it helps me more to look at it in a much
simpler way
i look at it as a dominant 7th chord
with
a whole tone scale infused together
dominant seventh chord
and a whole tone scale
more specifically the way that i
personally view and understand the
formation of this chord is quite
simple again starting with a dominant
seventh chord i'm going to voice it like
so
so this is a c7 see dominant 7th chord
i'm going to keep certain pitches in
place and i'm going to take
some pitches and push them upwards by a
whole step
i'm going to take this e here the g
here and the c here
and just push them up a whole step
and now we have the mystic
card what's unique about scri alvin is
that he'll use this
not as just a fancy seventh chord but
he'll
play with this suspended quality and
he'll take it sort of
anywhere he he wants almost opus 57
number one
the opening here once the b is resolved
by half step
we have the bottom four notes of the
mystic chord
with that in mind you can perhaps look
at this
first chord as some form of a c7
all right i think that's an appropriate
place to stop in terms of analyzing some
of his scores
really this can be so endless but i'm
going to focus on the transition between
his early period
to his middle period because i'm going
to write an arrangement
of happy birthday in the style of
scriabin and i just need to cap it
somewhere i've been reading a lot about
skriyabin's
life some of his poems i've been trying
to understand
more of maybe the reasoning why he was
writing this material what he was going
for
because there's a lot of material on
this
matter he really put an emphasis on what
he's trying to achieve
with his art with his music describing
that in 15 you know
i played for him one year before he died
in 1914 i played for him
so i came here he was sitting like that
he was crazy you know and one day i
played the text 10 minutes and
the scavenger my mother i told you that
that he will be a pianist and whatever
but you have to educate him we should
know the
literature depending the the everything
outside of
the whole music to opera orchestra
that is difficult that you have to have
acquaintance with the world and
the world is sinking now it's not so
good
[Music]
it's also important to note that
scriabin had synesthesia which made him
perceive
certain sounds as colors this
significantly influenced the way he
wrote music
symphonic pain prometheus there is a
line in the score devoted to the color
or colors he wanted projected
during his performance like kandinsky
the russian painter
his exact contemporary and himself a
philosophies
he held views on the spiritual role of
art
and on the role of the artist in the
whole scheme of the universe
screaming believed he was someone very
special
someone through whom ideas could be
expressed so as to influence
all mankind to be honest a lot of this
goes over my head it's really hard to
follow
it's really hard to relate to sometimes
as well but
i found that reading about this and
focusing on this aspect of his music
making was
actually helping me come up with certain
ideas for these arrangements
i've already written most of it i'm just
refining certain details at this point
and i'll just go over what i included
and why
this is the intro i wanted something
ambiguous something
not quite settled yet but very delicate
very hopeful
and wistful
so now here the happy birthday theme
[Music]
the difficult thing about this theme is
that
so much of the harmony and the rhythm is
baked into
the theme when it's recognizable so as
soon as you try to change it
it either sounds nothing like happy
birthday
or it's just it sounds like nothing like
the composers
i'm using a stacked fourth chord and i'm
voice leading in a similar way to
scriabin where we have common tones and
then
we're sliding downwards or upwards so
instead of just playing these chords
[Music]
i'm opening these up
[Music]
with the left hand thumb
[Music]
scrub and loves these fourths and
tritones so
i feel like that's appropriate note that
a lot of these left hand figures are
going
top to bottom so if we were to play
bottom to top
it feels more grounded just same notes
with the direction reversed
[Music]
it's really different here i want to end
the phrase with
an after major chord and if i do
something like this
[Music]
very straightforward one two three one
two three on the grid it doesn't feel
right for this type of style
in in scrabbon's world so i'm going to
place the notes in a much more fluid
manner
[Music]
there we go something like that
a little chopinesque line here
[Music]
here i'm just abandoning
that little fragment it's there but
[Music]
a little shift
[Music]
a quote of opus 32 number one
and i repeat it twice and
that end here
flat sixth rub so you don't even feel
like anything's ever resolved
i decided to start a second prelude so
here i
started to write
this as the leading motive
tritones also this
trochee
[Music]
i feel like these bubba buck cords
just adds a little bit of nervous energy
here
a frantic leap upwards here
and here i want to do something with the
left hand where i'm
something like that
[Music]
something you always have this sort of
noble yet bold daring raw raw
type of energy
probably something wider like that
unnecessarily difficult
yeah something like that flailing
upwards
and here i was thinking of trill
[Music]
this is the general idea and i'm going
to work on it again refine some details
and then take it to the piano
now here is happy birthday in the style
of scriabin presented in the form of two
short preludes
[Music]
thank you all for watching and
subscribing and a special thank you to
all of my supporters on patreon for
helping me make videos like this one